[Musique]
merci
il y a beaucoup de circulation sur la route, je suis
allé vers l'île comme ça tout le
temps tous les jours ouvrables
parce que c'est là que les Géorgiens
marchent tout
droit,
ça fait partie de la vie quotidienne des
gens à Lagos.  je suis confronté à beaucoup de stress à cause de
la route,
bon après-midi
[Musique]
donc je suis sûr que vous savez que Lagos est une
ville encombrée, nous devons donc évidemment
trouver des alternatives, c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement de l'État a entrepris un
développement durable du
transport par eau  système
étranger,
c'est
le principal, votre principal défi est
qu'il y a des problèmes de
mise en œuvre, c'est vraiment du financement, mais
s'ils réussissent, il y
aura un changement majeur dans la donne
étrangère.